Hai dan selamat datang semula ke siri kursus Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan dalam video ni kita akan terokai cara untuk mewakili
masalah VQE dalam bentuk yang boleh difahami oleh komputer kuantum.
Biasanya, masalah kimia kuantum dinyatakan dalam bentuk tenaga
sistem tersebut.
Kita merujuk kepada operator yang menerangkan tenaga-tenaga ini sebagai Hamiltonian.
Pertama, kita perlu mengkuantumkannya.
Iaitu, menyatakannya dalam bahasa kimia kuantum,
yang secara rasminya dipanggil kuantisasi kedua.
Kalau Hamiltonian menerangkan interaksi fermion, contohnya,
tenaga elektron dalam orbital spin, kita merujuknya
sebagai Hamiltonian fermionik, dan itulah titik permulaan kita hari ini.
Qubit pula ada bahasanya sendiri.
Operator dalam dunia qubit diterangkan oleh operator Pauli.
Jadi fokus kita di sini adalah untuk menyatakan operator fermionik
dalam bentuk operator qubit.
Ada padanan satu-ke-satu yang mudah antara
keadaan sifar dan satu bagi fermion dan qubit.
Jadi pemetaan antara keadaan-keadaan tu pun mudah juga.
Tapi, pemetaan operator pula agak lebih kompleks sikit.
Hamiltonian fermionik dinyatakan dengan operator penciptaan dan
operator pemusnahan.
Jadi tugas kita adalah untuk memudahkan komputer kuantum memahami
Hamiltonian tersebut.
Kita akan guna alat matematik untuk memetakan Hamiltonian fermionik
kepada Hamiltonian qubit dengan gate.
Jadi dengan kata lain, kita akan menterjemahkan antara
bahasa kimia kuantum dan bahasa pengkomputeran kuantum.
Bayangkan dua rantai, satu dengan fermion,
iaitu bahasa kimia kuantum.
Dan satu lagi dengan qubit, iaitu bahasa pengkomputeran kuantum.
Pada pandangan pertama, pemetaan tu nampak mudah, kan?
Dalam kedua-dua kes, kita nampak sistem dengan dua aras.
Untuk fermion, kita ada sama ada satu fermion dalam keadaan itu
atau tiada fermion langsung.
Dan untuk qubit, kita ada sama ada keadaan 0 atau keadaan 1.
Tapi sebenarnya ia lebih rumit dari tu.
Perbezaan antara rantai qubit dan rantai fermion
adalah sesuatu yang sangat asas dalam fizik: apa yang kita panggil simetri pertukaran.
Dua fermion tidak boleh menduduki keadaan yang sama.
Tapi untuk rantai qubit, ini adalah sesuatu yang berbeza sama sekali.
Dua qubit boleh berada dalam keadaan yang sama,
sebab qubit bukan fermion.
Kita kena cari cara untuk menterjemah antara dua rantai tu.
Sejak tahun 1928 lagi, dua penyelidik, Jordan dan Wigner,
telah tunjukkan bahawa operator fermionik untuk keseluruhan rantai
boleh diwakili dengan tepat dalam bentuk operator qubit.
Inilah pemetaan yang paling mudah untuk komputer kuantum.
Contohnya, kita boleh guna kaedah ni untuk memetakan penghunian
sebuah orbital kepada spin satu qubit.
Secara praktikalnya, pemetaan ini untuk Hamiltonian menghasilkan jumlah berwajaran operator Pauli.
Ini adalah fakta yang sangat penting, yang saya nak korang ingat,
dan kita akan kembali kepada ini dalam modul seterusnya di mana kita akan bincang
tentang cara circuit variasi dilaksanakan pada komputer kuantum.
Pemetaan di atas bermaksud jika kita ada, contohnya,
14 operator fermionik, kita akan petakan masalah itu kepada 14 qubit.
Nasib baik, ada cara-cara bijak untuk mengurangkan bilangan qubit
dan guna sumber kuantum yang lebih sedikit untuk dapat prestasi lebih baik dari komputer kuantum.
Biasanya, dalam sistem molekul, kita akan tahu
beberapa simetri fizikal Hamiltonian,
misalnya, jumlah bilangan elektron adalah tetap.
Maklumat ini boleh digunakan untuk mengurangkan saiz masalah
tanpa kehilangan apa-apa maklumat yang relevan.
Kita panggil teknik ini pengurangan ruang aktif.
Ini membolehkan pengurangan jumlah sumber, iaitu bilangan qubit,
sebelum pemetaan qubit seperti transformasi Jordan-Wigner.
Langkah ini mengira Hamiltonian berkesan
dan membolehkan kita guna lebih sedikit qubit hasilnya.
Untuk contoh kita dengan 14 orbital,
teknik ini mengurangkan bilangan qubit kepada hanya enam sahaja.
Kita boleh pergi lagi jauh dengan pengurangan-pengurangan ini.
Kita boleh guna pemetaan yang berbeza,
yang sedikit lebih canggih berbanding Jordan-Wigner.
Contoh paling biasa adalah pemetaan pariti.
Pemetaan pariti tidak memetakan penghunian orbital pada qubit,
tapi sebaliknya memetakan pariti orbital kepada qubit tunggal.
Kita tak akan masuk ke dalam butiran matematik di sini,
tapi yang penting untuk diketahui adalah pemetaan ini mengandungi
kelebihan lebihan yang boleh dimanfaatkan untuk menghapuskan dua lagi qubit.
Jadi, contoh kita dengan 14 orbital, berkurang dari 14 qubit
kepada 6 qubit dengan pengurangan ruang aktif dan kemudian kepada 4 qubit
dengan pengurangan dua qubit dalam pemetaan pariti.
Jom kita sebut sekejap satu transformasi lagi.
Satu lagi pemetaan yang kerap digunakan antara representasi fermionik
dan qubit adalah transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev.
Transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev menggunakan qubit untuk mengekod maklumat
tentang nombor penghunian dan pariti keadaan kuantum.
Transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev menggabungkan maklumat nombor penghunian dan pariti
untuk asas orbital molekul bersaiz N,
di mana N qubit digunakan sekali lagi.
Tapi, maklumat yang tersimpan dalam setiap qubit
kini berbeza-beza bergantung pada qubit yang mana.
Iaitu, apabila indeks qubit adalah genap,
ia menyimpan nombor penghunian bagi
nombor orbital yang berpadanan seperti dalam pemetaan Jordan-Wigner.
Apabila indeks qubit adalah ganjil, qubit menyimpan pariti bagi
set nombor penghunian tertentu. Transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev adalah yang paling cekap
apabila bilangan qubit menghampiri kuasa dua.
Pemetaan Bravyi-Kitaev menggabungkan kelebihan dari Jordan-Wigner
dan transformasi pariti.
Ia mengurangkan bilangan qubit yang setiap sebutan Hamiltonian bertindak ke atasnya,
Ini penting untuk simulasi kuantum kerana sebutan-sebutan
yang bertindak ke atas bilangan qubit yang besar dalam Hamiltonian
memerlukan circuit yang lebih panjang untuk simulasinya.
Ini bermakna kedalaman circuit
dikurangkan dengan transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev dan secara amnya
kita boleh dapat hasil yang lebih baik dengan perkakasan.
Ini adalah penambahbaikan berbanding transformasi Jordan-Wigner
yang menghasilkan Hamiltonian qubit tertib N.
Jadi, dalam video ni kita dah terokai kaedah-kaedah untuk memetakan
Hamiltonian fermionik kepada Hamiltonian qubit.
Dalam video seterusnya kita akan tengok macam mana nak pilih keadaan
dan bentuk variasi atau circuit dengan sebaik-baiknya.
Jumpa korang nanti.